all right let's hear from a few more
people when we take calls we do so via
discord you can find our discord at
davidpakman.com
discord let's go to ben
from san angelo ben welcome to the show
hello can you hear me david i can hear
you fine
okay great
um now i have a question to ask you
about the u.s presidency okay um are you
familiar with the c-span's presidential
historian survey no
okay um well i really like it it was
last updated in 2021
um it asked about 140
um different
uh
i guess historians what they thought
about the presidents
and um i guess my question is
do you think that um
using the
survey here is a good way to
sort of talk to others about you know
presidents and the really bad presidents
versus the really good ones
um i mean listen i'm looking at it now
and just to give people context
basically the historians rank the
presidents and
lincoln basically is always number one
george washington goes between two and
three fdr goes between three and two
teddy roosevelt is almost always in
fourth when you look at recent
presidents um barack obama
was uh ranked i guess it's like around
10th
trump is ranked fourth to the worst the
the only people ranked worse than trump
per historians are franklin pierce
andrew johnson and james buchanan here's
the thing i think this is interesting
but if you try to tell someone who's
like some kind of trumpist or right
winger about it they'd go the historians
are just left-wing shills and they'll
just ignore it you know
okay
that was my question but thank you oh no
problem yeah i mean i i hate to be like
kind of cynical but if they don't like
what it says they'll just say it's not
worth listening to you know
all right okay well he left i guess
maybe my answer was not uh not not
suitable but that's okay